[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
réussir la rénovation énergétique
selon l'Observatoire national de la
rénovation énergétique deux tiers du
parc de logement attendent d'être rénové
et 5,6 millions de ménages souffrent de
précarité énergétique
réussir la rénovation énergétique des
logements est un défi qui touche au cœur
de la vie des Français en liant la fin
du monde c'est-à-dire les grands
équilibres climatiques et la fin du mois
à savoir la grande difficulté de nos
concitoyens à payer leurs factures
d'énergie la France s'est donnée pour
objectif de rénover 370 000 logements
par an d'ici 2030 et 700000 au dollars
mais avec moins de 100.000 rénovations
globales en 2022 elle en est loin alors
même que plus de 8 milliards par an sont
dépensés pour la rénovation énergétique
chaque année
pour changer la donne et relever ainsi
le défi de l'accélération de la
rénovation énergétique la commission
d'enquête mise en place par le Sénat à
retenu une vingtaine de propositions
autour de quatre axes principaux le
premier axe consiste à définir une
stratégie stabilité ambitieuse et
solidaire il s'agit de préserver un mix
énergétique équilibré et résilient
d'adopter un calendrier réaliste de
réduction du gaz fossile tout en
promouvant les rénovations les plus
efficaces le deuxième axe vise à
redonner confiance à fiabiliser les
outils et à ancrer la rénovation dans
les territoires
en ce sens elle préconise de mobiliser
plusieurs leviers pour mieux lutter
contre la fraude elle propose par
ailleurs de replacer les collectivités
locales au cœur de l'information et de
l'accompagnement le troisième axe de la
commission d'enquête en temps garantir
les financements de la rénovation
énergétique par exemple en portant les
crédits de ma prime rénov à 4,5
milliards d'euros en 2024 enfin le
rapport formule une série de
propositions afin de structurer une
filière industrielle française de la
rénovation par exemple en formant 200
000 professionnels d'ici 2030 et en
apportant un soutien à la relocalisation
de la filière française de matériaux et
d'équipements notamment de pompes à
chaleur
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]